when I was eight years old yay high and
in overalls I went to be an astronaut
and a marine biologist and a
paleontologist an artist and a racecar
driver I wanted to know what the rocks
on Pluto tasted like whether or not the
trembling vibrations from a stampeding
herd of Triceratops would really Clank
my teeth I was brought to Canada when I
was three years old my dad left his job
managing a thousand people at a beer
bottling factory to pump gas at Shell
and like many immigrants he did this so
that my brothers and I could have a
better life there's something he always
used to say he said money isn't
everything but without money you have
nothing I think he was trying to teach
us what the majority of our economically
driven society teaches us get a job that
pays as much as possible in a position
that is secure in an industry that is
stable and so when I walk through those
ironclad gates in my first year of
college I wasn't gonna be an astronaut I
was gonna be a doctor I was disappointed
sure but that's the way the world works
money is the only constant it's the only
power it's the only objective make
enough money to buy the stuff you want
don't you want that beautiful Victorian
house off of the coast don't you want to
drive that latest Tesla Model S don't
you want to throw a party so lavish it
would make Gatsby turn in his grave be
honest
you kind of do and I kind of do too
the basic assumption of our modern
society is that more money equals more
pleasure but something about that didn't
feel right to me and I'm sure that if
you're sitting in this room right now
you also have an inkling that money can
only get you so far I'm sure that if
somebody asked you today what means the
most to you and why you wouldn't say
dolla dolla bills y'all
I'm not saying that money is bad I'm
just saying it's not enough and so two
years into my undergrad one Christmas I
went to my dad I said dad I'm not gonna
be a doctor anymore because I think
money and security are overrated you
should have seen the look on his face
and when I showed my best friend he
referred me to this book it was the
4-hour workweek by Tim Ferriss
now Tim is a Stanford undergrad and or a
grad now and he became allowed an
eccentric voice in a movement against
the traditional notions of money
insecurity he said that it was better to
have freedom rather than money to live
like a millionaire than be one to set
your own hours to not have a boss to
determine your own fate to be able to
work from every mountain or forest or
beach anywhere in the world for hours a
week and spend the rest of it just
exploring the hidden trails of old
cities or just floating on a yacht be
honest you kind of want that and I kind
of do too so I did it between 2011 and
2013 my best friend and I started a web
design firm turned our office mobile and
traveled the world in two years we went
to 21 countries in 59 cities we bungee
jumped off the Macao Tower checked out
Everest base camp and scuba dived off
the coast of Cambodia we ate lunch at
four world wonders celebrated five new
years the best Pad Thai in the world is
in sir sock and the best biryani at a
train station between Darjeeling and
Calcutta we witnessed the protests live
in Turkey and Egypt and shared a power
outage with 600 million Indian citizens
we did all of this working about four
hours a day four days a week
we made 18,000 dollars per person per
year and we could have done it forever
but we didn't
see at the end of the two years I was
exhausted I was lost I was lonely my
social circles would reset every 90 days
and my only solace was the next
experience I had planned the next high I
would feel I found that unlimited
freedom becomes lethargic and new
experiences became my drug I'm not
saying that freedom is bad but for me it
wasn't enough and so will riding sleeper
class on a train from Varanasi to Delhi
I whipped out my iPhone and I started
typing up my application to the Graduate
School of Business
Stanford spoke to the part of me that
yearned for something more it said that
the right way to live was to live a life
where you could change things change
lives change organizations change the
world so that my life could have meaning
so that all of the investment that has
been poured into me all of the privilege
I have yet to earn would result in
something influential to be meaningful
and to not be wasted
be honest you kind of want that and I
kind of do too
so when I got into Stanford I was so
excited I was this close to living the
life that I thought I wanted or I think
I want and so the summer before arriving
to sunny California I visited Stefan
Stefan is my closest mentor he was my
high school philosophy teacher and he
has four kids and if you know anybody
with four kids you also know that they
have this permanent calmness about them
and so I went to Stefan I said Stef I'm
going to revolutionize the entire
education system I'm gonna affect
millions and millions of kids and
hundreds of thousands of schools I don't
really know how I'm gonna do it or how
it's gonna work but it's gonna happen
and it's gonna make an impact so Stefan
laughs and he smiles and then he asks me
a question that I've been asking myself
every single day since then he said are
you doing that because you want to
matter or because you think it matters
are you doing it because you want to
matter or because you think it matters
I'm not really sure how to tell the
difference well then you better figure
it out because it's the difference
between being the villain and the hero
so I racked my brain for days for weeks
for months and made a list of all the
heroes I had the people I looked up to
in my family from Forbes from fiction
and a pattern emerged seems that all the
heroes I had they they all dedicated
their lives to something that was truly
meaningful to them for my father it was
myself and my brothers for Nelson
Mandela it was South Africa for
Beethoven who was music for Einstein it
was physics for Dumbledore it was
Hogwarts they all cultivated something
and when someone cultivates something
their self indulgent desires seem
trivial and not in a willing to give up
comfort today to get comfort tomorrow
kind of way they're willing to give up
comfort permanently if it furthers their
cause when someone cultivates something
it's not about a milestone or
achievement they're never doing it for
an award or a certificate or status
they're doing it because it can always
be better it's work that can last a
lifetime when someone cultivates some
and they see it done better elsewhere
they're not jealous or anxious they're
inspired and they're invigorated when
someone cultivates something they're
willing to give up money for it they're
willing to give up freedom for it and
they're willing to give up feeling
important for it see the things we
cultivate define us they make us feel
grounded they tell us who we are how
much money you have doesn't define you
but what you're willing to give your
money up for does how much freedom you
have doesn't define you but what you're
willing to give your freedom up for does
how much power you have doesn't define
you but what you're willing to give to
give your power up for does five months
ago when I started writing this talk I
wasn't really sure what I wanted to do
for the summer or post graduating but in
articulating what it means to cultivate
it became undeniably clear what I wanted
to need it to do
so remember Stefan my mentor well the
summer the two of us are building a high
school a high school that places kids in
between philosophy and innovation so
that in the morning they'll reach
Shakespeare and in the afternoon they
learn entrepreneurship and though
banking will pay more and consulting
would probably allow me to travel again
nothing speaks to Who I am what I
believe in and what I stand for more
than the school to find the things that
we deem beautiful and then be willing to
give our all to cultivate it I'm going
to be honest I want that
do you